- [Narrator] For decades,
Italian engineers have
been working on designs
for a massive project,
one that could help solve
one of Southern Italy's biggest problems
by connecting 5 million people
in Sicily to the mainland,
bringing jobs and growth
to the economically
depressed southern regions.
The final goal, a $12.7
billion mega project
called the Messina Strait Bridge,
which if completed,
will be the world's
longest suspension bridge.
- Nobody has ever built such a big bridge,
so it is an incredible challenge.
- [Narrator] Building a bridge
that's more than two miles long
in an area with gale force winds
and frequent earthquakes
is neither easy nor cheap,
here's how Italy plans to pull it off.
To understand why this
trade is so dangerous,
here's a look at the tectonic fault lines
in the Mediterranean.
Experts say, this line,
which runs right under
the proposed bridge,
is where the Eurasian
and African tectonic plates meet.
Notoriously active, it caused
a 7.5 magnitude quake in 1908
and one 50 years later,
which reached 6.1 magnitude.
The fault line also created
this narrow corridor.
When winds from the south funnel into it,
they pick up speed as they're
squeezed into less space,
at times reaching up
to 170 miles per hour.
Winds like this can be
devastating for bridges.
In 1940, the Tacoma Narrows
suspension bridge in Washington
famously collapsed in high winds.
At the time,
it was the third longest
suspension bridge in the world.
So how are engineers planning
to tackle these challenges?
We visited Columbia's
engineering lab to learn more.
This is Raimondo Betti,
a suspension bridge expert.
He consulted on the Messina
bridge's early designs
in the 90s.
He says that a suspension
bridge gets its stability
from cables that attach the deck
to sets of towers supported
with vertical struts.
- So when you have a car
going over this bridge,
the car is on the deck.
Then the deck transferred this load
through the suspender to the main cable.
The main cable distributes
the load to the towers
and to the anchorages.
- The Messina Bridge will be held up
by two gigantic towers,
each 60 feet taller than
the Empire State building.
The deck will be 2.2 miles long
and take about 10 minutes to cross by car,
making it over 50% longer than
the current record holder,
the 6,637 foot long
Canakkale Bridge in Turkey,
- Messina is over three
kilometers free span.
So now you are pushing the envelope,
not just a few meters,
but you are pushing the envelope
of about almost a kilometer.
- [Narrator] While that jump in length
is a construction challenge,
it's also a solution to one
of those big environmental dangers.
Experts say that extra kilometer of deck
will help protect the bridge
from seismic activity.
Imagine this piece of balsa
wood is a bridge deck.
- This cross section is this long.
If I take this piece instead
and I bend it, this one
is much more flexible
because this is much more longer.
- The idea is that in an earthquake,
the deck will bend slowly
registering less seismic activity
like a large ship in small waves.
Moving upward, one of the bridge's
newest engineering developments
is these hourglass shaped struts.
They let the legs flex
more than a traditional
cross shaped strut when there's a quake.
Between the flexible deck and legs,
the bridge could theoretically withstand
a 7.5 magnitude earthquake,
the highest of any structure in the world.
- Seismic is going to be
important, but seismic,
we know how to design for seismic.
The major concern in my opinion
for this bridge is the wind.
- [Narrator] On a bridge,
strong winds can look like this.
- You might have excessive
motion of this bridge
sway left and right, left and right,
that impairs the traffic.
that people say, "I'm not going there."
- [Narrator] So to prevent that,
engineers created a new kind of deck,
the Messina type deck.
This cross section shows.
- Three box girders.
The two others were for vehicular traffic.
The inner one was for train traffic,
and then this box girders are connected
by a very tight skin of crossbars.
- [Narrator] All these lanes and tracks
will be capable of supporting
up to 6,000 cars per hour
and 200 trains per day.
And see how the side girders are tapered.
- The crosswind will kind of move over,
like an airplane wing,
and will not create too
much excessive motion.
- [Narrator] Principles of the deck,
which have been developed
over the course of decades,
have been tested in recent years.
- The Canakkale Bridge
use similar principle,
but it does not have the center one,
because it does not carry any train.
The Messina Bridge, this
is another challenge,
has been done for two,
but now you have to make
it three box together.
- [Narrator] With this deck,
engineers say the bridge could
stay standing with winds up
to 186 miles an hour.
That's as fast as the top wind speeds
of a category five hurricane.
But the high cost isn't the
only challenge to completion.
Critics have highlighted research
that high numbers of migrating birds
could collide with the bridge.
Experts say that could be devastating
to endangered species,
and there's even concern that the mafia
could influence construction contracts,
inflating costs, and adding risk.
Currently, officials plan
to break ground in mid 2024
and finish the bridge in the early 2030s.
So for now, this new world's
longest suspension bridge
is still a decade away.
(gentle music)